it's really clear right now that the
major engine
of wealth and I would also suggest
personal happiness is being able to
think different that's that's the
engines and when we're when we're all
connected to 24 hours a day around the
world with our little devices the true
value is being able to think a little
differently that's the source of
innovation that's how you make great
things that's how you make great art
travel and other experiences reading
different books than other people read I
mean there's lots of ways to do that but
you want to really cultivate that
ability to think differently in a world
where everybody's connected together all
the time